All right let's do this one last time
welcome back everyone this will be my
brand new spider-man across the spider-verse
trailer video they showed off a bunch of new
scenes so we'll break it down if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos there's still a lot of really
big spider-man stuff coming up even though
we just got tobey maguire and andrew garfield
spider-man back during spider-man no way home
so what are you gonna go into battle dressed
as a cool youth pastor or you got your suit
and quick reminder spider-man across the
spider-verse is a two-part movie that's
right they're doing the avengers infinity war and
avengers end game thing where they split the movie
into two different parts we're getting part one
next year in part two the year after that so there
won't be a giant wait for part two of the movie
one of the key differences between this movie
and the first spider-man into the spider-verse
movie is the first movie was all about other
characters coming to miles morales universe the
ultimate spider-man universe the sequels is going
to be the opposite it'll be him going to other
universes inside the spiderverse i've already
done a trailer video that they dropped earlier
this year so i'll link it at the end of this too
but if it wasn't clear from that when they travel
to other universes they use different animation
styles for each different version of spider-man's
universe so for example in the trailer there's a
lot of footage of miles morales traveling to this
alternate universe of spider-man india's universe
he's a hindu spider-man so everything's drawn in
an indian themed animation style for that country
the same is true when he goes to spider-man
2099's universe in nueva york in the future
also explained that too like how can he travel
in time when he's traveling between universes
but the first brand new scene that they showed off
was of spider gwen it started with a new scene of
gwen stacy's spider gwen voiced by haley steinfeld
who actually just showed up in the hawkeye series
in the live-action mcu universe as a version of
kate bishop she'll be part of the young avengers
but if you want to you could think of her as a
variant of kate bishop in the mcu they were going
to have cameos with tom holland's live-action
spider-man tobey maguire and andrew garfield
like they did in spider-man no way home but at the
time a couple years ago when they were developing
that first movie remember this is a couple
years ago sony said that that was way too meta
way too weird to mix in live-action elements and
try to say that all these universes are connected
cut to now when we just had spider-man no way home
in doctor strange two multiverse of madness and
things have gotten pretty weird so i think it's
pretty safe to say that it's okay to do that now
but gwen stacy's spider-gwen's earth is on earth
65 within this spider-man across the spider-verse
multiverse it was drawn in the same style when
we saw her universe while she was narrating her
backstory during the first movie with the
visual dials cranked up to 11 it looked way
more beautiful than like the normal ultimate
spider-man miles morales universe everything
is drawn in water colors layered brush strokes
paper textures it's meant to look very beautiful
compared to the normal universe that you would
think of in ultimate spider-man's universe in the
clip you see gwen stacy's dad george stacy voiced
by shea winningham that was actually a big reveal
too that he's voicing the character who's meant
to be a by the books cop in the movie responding
to a disturbance at the guggenheim museum because
spider-gwen is trying to be a superhero she beats
him there and tries to solve the crime before he
shows up and when she shows up at the guggenheim
museum she meets a bunch of the other variants
of spider-man from other universes she meets
spider-man 2099 voiced by oscar isaac who's also
moon knight in the live-action mcu universe that
we just saw a version of jessica drew spider
woman from another universe voiced by issa rae
remember both of their universes would be
completely different looking from spider-gwen's
universe and from ultimate spider-man miles
morales universe and she also winds up meeting
a version of the vulture voiced by yorma tacon
who actually voiced the green goblin in the first
movie so like he's back voicing a completely
different character so another big reveal was
that a version of vulture would be in the movie
but just like all the characters that you see
in the first spider-man into the spider-verse
movie they're all a little bit different than
what you've seen in the live-action spider-man
movies before so he's very different from say
like michael keaton's version of the vulture and
one of the funny things they did with jessica drew
spider-woman in the movie is that they made her
super pregnant like she is in her comic book like
she's still meant to be a badass but she's got
this giant pregnant belly for most of the movie
so part of the comedy is her swinging around
beating the crap out of all these villains
while she's super pregnant then they clarified a
little bit about what's going on with spider-man
2099 in the context of this animated multiverse
during the movie they explained that miguel o'hara
isn't supposed to have regular spider-man powers
he wasn't bitten by a radioactive bug the same
way that ultimate spider-man was in the movie just
like the comics he actually does a gene splicing
treatment and gives himself arachne-like powers
so he doesn't wind up getting the spidey sense
but he does have some spider-man-based powers
like he has super strength he can climb walls
and because he's from the future a lot of the
advanced tech in the movie like the webware that
allow them to travel between universes come from
him one of the cool abilities that he'll have in
the movie is also a giant laser web then there was
a completely different scene of miles morales just
kind of showing what's going on in his daily life
before things go completely off the rails for him
it's been a couple years since the first movie
he's grown up a little bit he's learning to
balance his school life with his home life and
his superhero life as the ultimate version of
spider-man he's got the upgraded version of the
suit with the new looking version of the logo
and in the scene he's not wearing the costume he's
running late for a meeting between him his parents
and his regular school counselor just a
regular person voiced by rachel dratch
miles is meant to have a ton on his mind getting
into the college of his dreams because he's
getting ready to go to college keeping his city
safe as spider-man to being a good son to his
parents so he's just trying to juggle everything
all at once then while he's on the way to this
meeting that he's late for his spidey sense goes
up and he winds up running into the new villain of
the film for the first time called the spot even
though he might not be the ultimate villain of
both of these films because it's a two-part film
like avengers infinity war in avengers end game
essentially he's voiced by jason schwartzman and
he's a huge deep cut from the comics you see both
him and spider-gwen fighting him in this scene
that they release here like you see him trying
to kick him but he's using one of the portals on
his body one of his abilities to cause his leg to
come out and kick spider gwen on accident spot's
whole body is covered in interdimensional portals
made to feel like living ink in the movie the way
they animated it and he can send people anywhere
he wants them to go including himself he can also
make portals appear out of thin air away from his
body and transport objects and people at will they
said spot's character design the way they animated
him in the movie is meant to evoke unfinished
sketches with blue construction lines representing
the artist's rough outline before work is then
sent to be inked so there's this big easter egg in
the way that they animated him they said that they
thought it would be really cool if they used the
spots portals making them feel like living ink had
spilled and splattered all over a comic artist's
drawing and even though his power is meant to be
very simple in concept it's meant to prevent this
really big challenge for miles morales they
said the spot's design will change and grow
as the movie goes on representing the character's
mastery of his own powers it's the same thing that
happened to miles morales during the events of the
first film when miles first got his powers they
animate him at 12 frames a second to show how kind
of jumpy and unsure he is and then towards the end
of the film as he becomes more sure of himself
and learns more about his powers they start
animating his character at 24 frames a second so
he looks way more smooth way more sure of himself
the same thing is true in the sequel they animate
him at a faster frames per second rate so that he
seems more smooth more sure of himself because
a couple years have gone by the spot's real name
is jonathan own he was a college roommate with
quentin beck mysterio in college originally he
was a scientist working for kingpin this is the
connection back to the events of the first film he
started out working for kingpin who tasked him in
recreating the cloaks dark force powers remember
it's all about using the dark force to teleport
but in an accident he wound up traveling to an
alternate dimension that they just called the
spotted dimension full of portals when he found
the portal back to his earth in return he found
that his entire body had been mutated covered
in the portals he could generate portals all over
his body and transport himself different distances
at will it sounds like in the movie eventually he
will be able to transport himself across universes
his main weakness is that there is a limit to the
number of portals that he can throw or generate
once he begins to hit his limit his body begins to
turn solid white and that's when he becomes really
weak to spider-man's attacks so the trick is just
to extend him past his limit my early theory is
that miles morales and the others will just defeat
him with the help of them all working together
like a multiverse tag team with all the versions
of spider-man fighting him at the same time
just pushing him past his limit in the amount
of portals that he can create they did confirm
that peter b parker's midlife crisis spider-man
is coming back for the movie and even though he
wasn't in the brand new footage that they just
showed off earning the trailer they confirmed
that the 1970s japanese spider-man spider-man is
going to be in the movie his universe for example
would be animated in traditional anime style
i've already done a much longer trailer video
for the other footage they dropped late last year
so i'll post a link down in the description below
but if you have any questions about what's going
on in the movie or what's going on with these two
different parts of the movie just let me know
in the comments and i'll try to add those to
my bonus videos we'll get another trailer later
this year the movie is coming out june 2nd 2023
speaking of live-action spider-man stuff though it
is still possible for them to work in cameos for
tom holland tobey maguire and andrew garfield's
live-action versions of spider-man and it sounds
like it's probably going to wind up being about
a three-year time gap for spider-man 3. so we'll
probably hear something about what's going on
with that next year usually winds up being about
two years before the release date before they
really start making noise about that everyone
click here for my brand new thor love and thunder
trailer video in easter eggs and click here for
my brand new marvel thunderbolts announcement
video that's right they're doing thunderbolts
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!